bueno esta vez valentina desde el liceo
de aplicación en el centro de santiago
donde ya se están llevando a cabo el
recuento de los votos las urnas cerraron
aproximadamente hace una hora y no hay
todavía por tanto datos oficiales sobre
la participación que se conocerán en
aproximadamente una hora y media más hay
prevista una primera información del
servicio electoral que ofrecerá datos no
sabemos si en concreto de participación
pero si sabemos que ayer partir del
sábado en la primera jornada de votación
participó un 20% de las personas
llamadas a votar del total de 14
millones 900 mil chilenos convocados a
las urnas más de 3 millones de personas
votaron un poquito más de 3 millones y
la participación en el día del domingo
en el segundo la segunda jornada ha sido
mucho menor por lo que hemos podido
observar había menos filas en los
colegios electorales y todo el mundo con
el que hemos podido charlar muchos
electores mucha gente que chica acudió a
votar ha manifestado su decepción por el
hecho de que las personas no acudieron a
las urnas como lo hicieron para el
plebiscito de octubre
patricia las autoridades han informado
hacia que ahora se tendrán los
resultados de estas elecciones
bueno son unas elecciones como tú bien
decías unas macro elecciones porque son
elecciones alcaldes gobernadores
concejales y también candidatos
constituyentes son las elecciones más
masivas de la historia de chile y por
tanto los chilenos están acostumbrados a
tener resultados apenas dos horas de
cerradas las urnas pero en este caso se
prevé que los resultados se conozcan a
lo largo de toda la noche incluso pasada
la medianoche chilena incluso podría
alargarse durante la madrugada porque
también en el caso de la convención
constituyente hay que hacer los ajustes
de paridad para asegurarse que la
conformación de esa constituyente es
paritaria entre hombres y mujeres además
de aplicar el sistema de electoral de la
ley de ohm sobre las listas sobre los
partidos por lo tanto son unas
elecciones especialmente complejas que
van a llevar mucho más tiempo conocer
los resultados finales de lo que es
habitual para los chilenos